اعتقد من الدول الغرب البلقان مقربه جدا
من يجب بتعرفي بان في ان تقع في وسط هذه
القارب اوكرا يا بعد 500 كلم فقط
البوسنه والهرسك ومنطقه باكملها بالنسبه
لان هذه المنطقه ليست باحه ورق الخلفيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي
الاوروبيه اوروبا
النمسا رئيسه للاتحاد الاوروبي في عام
2006 برنامج ولكن الان اقمنا بتجنيدها لان
التركيه
للاسفاء في عده اعصاعده مثل حوريات
الاعلام حقوق الانسان وحكم القانون
ابتعدت عن الاتحاد الاوروبي بدلا من
الاقتراب من ولهذا فن الدول الاعضاء 27
انا ممتنه جدا لهذه العلاقات والصداقه
المقربه تجمعنا مع الامارات العربيه
المتحده العديد من اصدقائي كما قد اسسنا
شرك استراتيجيين وثمنها كثيرا ونرغب
بتعزيزها وتطبيقها ولكنها ليست محصوره فقط
العربيه السعوديه
خليجي دورها ركيزي وحام جدا على صعيد
الامني والاقتصادي والطاقه
لطالما جماعتها علاقات ودوده وصديقه بهم
لاننا من الدول الاوروبيه القليل التي ليس
لديها اي ماضي استعماري
ولاطالما اه وخاصه الماضيه دائما كانت
تجمعنا علاقات الثقه ومقرب الدول العربيه
واتمنى ان نستمر بذلك للمستقبل